I don't know about nfts Gary I'm worried
about those
you shouldn't be you know not every card
not every piece of art not every sneaker
is worth something just like we talked
about during that summer 99 we're
destined to not be the most profound
thing for every Jackson Pollock and Andy
Warhol and Michael Jordan rookie card in
Collectibles there's 99 of things that
don't matter in the an excitement of 18
months ago people assumed every single
one was going to be but we we've
obviously become more educated and and
that's the Ebbs and flows of every
market and this viewership knows more
than anybody on Earth the Ebbs and flows
of supply and demand